[Music]
my name is Dees and I'm a PhD student at
Mila and University of Montreal I'm from
Iran my research is about the
intersection of Applied Mathematics and
theoretical computer science and machine
learning my ultimate goal as a
researcher as a female researcher is to
contribute and to direct my research to
the cancer especially the stage four
cancer because there is no cure and it's
not predictable after 4 years I have the
same feeling that Mila is like a magic
place for me the environment is so
friendly I love connecting with people
with diverse background uh and it's very
openminded uh environment I'm so happy
that I'm at Mila because I am learning a
lot from people every
day